Welcome back.
Whenever I start running out
of time I rush things and I
most probably confuse you.
So let me go over that last
example one more time.
So I said I have a completely
fair coin and I'm going to
flip it twice, and I want to
know the probability that
I get heads in both times.
Well, we already know the
probability that I get heads
the first time is 1/2.
There's 1/2 chance I get heads
the first time and there's
1/2 chance that I get
tails the first time.
And then I'm going to flip
again, and let's say, in this
world, there's a 1/2 chance
that we enter into this reality
where the first flip is heads,
and then in that world I'm
going to flip a coin again.
And I know that there's a half
a chance of heads-- this is
the second flip-- and
1/2 chance of tails.
And I know in this other
world-- I'll just draw it
so we can figure out maybe
other probabilities.
I know that there's 1/2
chance of heads, so this
is for the second flip.
And I know that there's
1/2 chance of tails
on the second flip.
And just so you know, this is
called a probability tree.
And in general, it works
excellent if you're not
dealing with huge numbers.
If you're not dealing with--
I'm doing 100 trials or the
probabilities get really messy
or in each trial there's 50
different circumstances
that can occur.
In this situation there's two
branches per-- you could say
per node, so there's not that
many circumstances that
can occur on each trial.
And we're not doing that
many trials, so it's
pretty manageable.
And in these situations,
the probability tree
works really well.
You can never get overwhelmed
with the information then.
And I'll show you, we'll do
some pretty complicated
examples using
probability tree.
There's no reason why I
actually circled that with
yellow; I just happened
to switch to yellow.
But anyway, just so you know,
this was the first trial.
This is the second trial.
We want to know the probability
of getting here because we got
heads on the first trial,
heads in the second.
Well, we know that there was a
1/2 chance of getting there and
then we know of that 1/2 or you
know, 1/2 the times we got
here, 1/2 of those times
you would get there.
So the probability of getting
there is 1/2 times 1/2,
which is equal to 1/4.
Another way of thinking about
it is each of these scenarios--
this is a scenario heads, heads
because you got a heads
and then a heads.
This is the scenario
heads, tails.
tails, heads.
You got a tail, then
you got a heads.
And this is the
scenario tails, tails.
And all of these are equally
probable scenarios.
There's no reason why one is
more likely than the other.
And so we have 4 equally
probable scenarios, so
the total of equally
probable scenarios is 4.
How many of these equal
probable scenarios is our
probability or our event true?
Well, it's one of
them-- heads heads.
So it's 1/4.
So that's another
way of viewing it.
Another way you could view it
is if we did this trial a
hundred times, if we did is a
hundred times, 50 of the times
my first flip will be heads.
And then of those 50 times 25
of those times-- half of those
trials where I got 50 the first
time will be heads again.
And so 25 out of the total 100
trials will end up with heads
heads, or this is 25% chance.
I wanted to show you that all
of these are pretty much the
equivalent, but I want your
brain to kind of connect
and make sure that it
understands everything.
So now that we've drawn this
probability tree I don't want
it to go to waste, so let me
give you another circumstance.
What's the probability I get
one heads and one tail?
And notice, I'm not saying that
it has to be in that order.
You know, it could be tails,
heads or heads, tail.
Let me write that down.
This is equal to the
probability of tails, heads
plus the probability
of heads, tails.
Or we could write that as-- and
this is kind of with set theory
notation, but it's good to be
familiar with all of these.
It's a probability of getting
tail, heads or this U looking
thing means or in set theory.
Or the probability of getting
heads, tails, right?
We can get tails, heads
or heads, tails.
In either of these we're
getting one heads
and one tails.
So what's that probability?
Well, we can just look at all
of the outcomes and we know
that there are 4 equally
probable outcomes.
And then, how many of these is
the event that we want true?
Well, it's 1, 2.
So there's a 2/4 or equal 1/4
chance where when we do both of
these flips we get at least one
heads and at least one tails.
And I think that's a good time
now that we've drawn this tree
and we've talked about two
flips in a row, to realize that
these are mutually
exclusive events.
The reason why we can multiply
the probability of the first
event times the probability of
the second event is because the
probability of getting heads
the second time is completely
independent of whether I
got heads the first time.
And that might be obvious to
you, but sometimes it isn't.
You know, some people feel that
if they got 5 heads in a row
that they're more likely to get
a tails on the sixth time.
But what we know from
experience really, is that no,
it's not like the coin knows
that you got 5 heads in a row
and then it says, oh boy, I
better give Sal a tails now
just to kind of make up for
all the 5 heads he got.
It's equally problems
to get a heads again.
So that's just something
to keep in mind.
And it's amazing how just human
beings psychologically-- you
feel that if you have a
big streak of heads that
you're due for a tails.
But your probability of getting
that tails does not increase.
Although, if you keep doing
it you're probability of
eventually-- the more times you
do it, the probability of
getting a tails does increase
and I'll show you that soon.
That last statement probably
confused you and I probably
shouldn't have said it.
Let's do an example.
Now that we know that in
mutually exclusive events
you can just multiply
the probabilities.
So let's say I have a fair coin
and what's the probability
of getting 5 heads in a row?
Well, I have a 1/2 chance of
getting heads the first time.
Then of those, 1/2.
Then another 1/2.
So it's 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2.
And that equals 1/2
to the fifth power.
That's equal to 1 over
2 to the fifth power.
And that's 1/32.
That's the probability of
getting 5 heads in a row.
What's the probability of
getting-- let's say I were
to flip a coin seven times.
So let's say I flip a coin, out
of seven times, what's the
probability of not
getting any heads?
I'm going to switch colors
just for the hell of it.
Well that might seem a little
bit more convoluted to you,
but just think about it.
The probability of out of the
seven flips of not getting
any heads, that is equal--
what has to be true then?
We got all tails then.
That's equal to the probability
of getting 7 tails in a row.
And what does that equal?
Well, the tails are equally
likely to the heads.
So that would be 1/2
to the seventh power.
That equals-- what is that?
So it'll be 4 times 132,
so that's equal to 1/128.
And a fun experiment to do is
maybe in your classroom or if
you have a large group of
people together, maybe 128 or
some large number of people
and you make everyone flip
a coin multiple times.
By the end of 5 or 6 or 7
flips, there will probably be--
and later on we'll actually
figure out the probability
that there is someone
who has a streak.
But there will probably be
someone who has a very long
streak of heads or tails.
And that person will probably
think that there's something
magical about what is going on
in their life at that moment.
And it's important to realize
if you have a large room, if
you have a room of 500 people,
someone's going to be getting--
there's a likelihood and we
haven't figured that out yet,
but just given that you have a
1 in 128 chance of getting 7
heads or 7 tails in a row.
Someone's going to get if you
have 500 people flipping coins.
But that person, they just view
their own reality, they think
that today is their lucky day.
And they think that they're on
some type of streak and that
they should go to Vegas.
But that's just something that
you should think about because
probability can often
play with our brains.
But anyway, I have 10
seconds left, so I will
see you in the next video.